in many parts of the world land has been
overworked and misused and it's
increasingly being swallowed up by the
effects of global warming heat waves and
droughts are turning ones fertile lands
into deserts that's the latest warning
from scientists I think the takeaway
message is that the way we use land
matters because it impacts the climate
and that we also should use land as a
solution the UN's Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change says global
warming and poor land use practices are
having devastating effects
entire communities have lost their crops
livestock land and livelihood
small-scale farmers who depend on rain
to grow their crops I left guessing
about when whether the rains are going
to come and whether they'll be enough so
it's it's really an urgent message to
governments the report calls on
governments to promote small-scale
farming and to significantly reduce
greenhouse gas emissions it also urges
consumers to do their part by reducing
meat consumption the way we produce food
and what we eat contributes to the loss
of natural ecosystems and declining
biodiversity it's estimated that one
third of the food produced for human
consumption about 1.3 billion tons goes
to waste every year the UN panel says
limiting the amount of voice wood free
land for reforestation and crop growth a
warning to stop pushing land to its
breaking point and a call for
governments to pay attention
katia lupus of the yawn al-jazeera